[Música]
bien cambiamos de tema en Reino Unido se
realizó el experimento de reducir la
semana laboral de 5 a 4 días en la
semana esto durante seis meses un
estudio en conjunto con la universidad
de Cambridge y con el Boston College que
llevó a participar a 3.000 empleados y
61 empresas la mayoría con menos de 25
Trabajadores al terminar este ejercicio
56 de las compañías decidieron adoptar
el modelo permanentemente vamos al
análisis con virginio Gallardo él es
socio consultor de Human Nova experto en
gestión del cambio y en recursos humanos
virginio Gracias por estar en directo a
América
Hola buenas tardes Buenos días
para empezar voy a citar un artículo de
nuestra cadena hermana r fi que dice que
los empleados se reportaron una gran
variedad de beneficios en cuanto a la
calidad del sueño a los niveles de
estrés la vida personal y la Salud
Mental a la vez los ingresos de las
empresas se mantuvieron sería Entonces
esta para usted ir Virginia una opción
viable y qué condiciones requerirían las
economías para hacer lo posible
bien a todos nos ha sorprendido el
estudio que tú mencionas el que hubo en
Irlanda o el que hizo la Ford week
global que es la digamos así una
fundación que intenta hacer esto en
varios países del Mundo incluso algunos
experimentos que se han hecho en España
también nos ha sorprendido Por qué
Porque no pensábamos que se podría
hablar de reducir la jornada laboral de
cinco días siempre entendemos sin
cambiar el salario y a la vez
incrementar la productividad de los
trabajadores esto parecía que se
encuentra sentido pero parece que
Efectivamente es así habría que hacer
más análisis Porque todavía digamos que
no tenemos muchos datos pero
efectivamente
para la empresa que no es un gran no les
perjudica la productividad incrementa y
por otra parte vemos algo que es muy
importante y es la mejora en la
satisfacción laboral de los trabajadores
curiosamente los trabajadores sobre todo
lo que hacen es dormir más esto es
sorprendente porque uno pensaría que
quizá pues descansan más se integran más
y todo esto incrementa todas las
variables relacionadas con el compromiso
y la retención del talento que es tan
importante como sabes para las empresas
de hoy en día por tanto yo creo que sí
que es una opción viable sobre todo en
países cuyo y en sectores cuya
productividad es alta Tenemos que tener
en cuenta que esto sobre todo se hace en
empresas que tienen trabajadores de
básicamente de cuello blanco más son las
más autores más se realiza y es donde
este tipo de fenómenos estamos viendo
que tiene estos efectos tan positivos
pareciera una novedad pero no lo ves que
una persona que duerme más pues también
va a ser una persona más funcional en
cualquier aspecto de su vida no y mire
de todas maneras hay detractores no
Aunque la productividad mejora
inicialmente Cuáles podrían ser las
consecuencias en el mediano y en el
largo plazo Esto se lo pregunto porque
los escépticos hablan del llamado efecto
haltron que supone Pues que cualquier
cambio en la rutina laboral podría
generar productividad inicial
efectivamente estos esto es posible esto
es perfectamente posible parecen muy
difícil y eso es cierto que
no solamente incrementes la
productividad durante un experimento dos
o tres meses sino que lo experimentes a
los cuatro o cinco años es posible que
haya un incremento de productividad esto
no lo sabemos por tanto los críticos
podrían Tener razón y efectivamente el
incremento de la productividad no ser
tan elevado como los estudios muestran
porque si no sería espectacular Sí
hombre si dices Bueno reduzco la jornada
Tengo a mis empleados más comprometidos
más contentos y encima producto más pues
esto no desaprueba probablemente
probablemente los escépticos Tengan algo
de razón no sabemos hasta qué punto
tienen razón pero probablemente tiene
alguna razón pero hay un fenómeno que yo
te diría que es mucho más importante de
todo esto hay un fenómeno que está
relacionado con la gran nation con la
renuncia silenciosa que es todavía peor
que resignación que es personas que se
queda puedes motivarse en el trabajo y
estamos viendo fenómenos que afectan a
nuevas generaciones relacionados con la
motivación es decir hay cambios
estructurales en el mercado de trabajo y
especialmente que afecten a las nuevas
organizaciones que dicen que
probablemente no queremos trabajar
tantas horas porque no nos beneficia y
preferimos optar por digámoslo así
trabajar menos horas la conciliación o
la flexibilidad esto estaría relacionado
quizá más con el trabajo
digamoslo así híbrido y este tipo de
temas que ganar más dinero y eso puede
ser un motivo para que los mejores
profesionales Los profesionales por
ejemplo con más capacidades de decidir
como pueden ser los tecnológicos se
decidan a ir empresas de este tipo por
eso ya en países como Francia hay un 5%
de empresas que ya hacen jornada laboral
de cuatro días por qué dónde sucede esto
sobre todo donde el talento digamos es
más escaso y donde tienes que digamos
adaptarte a las nuevas demandas
laborales que como vemos van por este
sentido pues es importante porque
justamente uno de los efectos de este y
otros estudios es que cuando se reduce
la jornada hay menos renuncias y menos
incapacidades de los empleados también
cabe preguntarnos cómo va a ser el
proceso de cambio porque usted ya estaba
mencionando un ejemplo en Francia
Bélgica lo va a hacer pero sin reducir
horas van a ser 40 horas divididas en
cuatro días Suecia lo está intentando y
en España es una discusión que está
latente recordemos también que en Chile
está la propuesta y Colombia ya está
implementando el camino para reducir las
horas laborales Así que cómo cómo se
plantea Este cambio en las estructuras
bien hay que decir una cosa
latinoamérica especialmente México y
otros países latinoamericanos están en
un contexto diferente a lo que puede ser
Europa
muchos países latinoamericanos hay un
exceso brutal de horas que yo creo que
claramente perjudica estas al menos mi
opinión perjudica la productividad
porque una persona que trabaja 50-55
horas probablemente tenga más problemas
ya empieza a tener problemas serios de
de productividad
pero bueno a largo plazo eh a corto
plazo por supuesto No al corto plazo No
pasa nada sino Simplemente si a una
persona durante seis meses siete meses
Está trabajando 60 horas Pues esa
persona pues te producirá un 15 o 20%
más pero claro a tres años probablemente
eso no sea así sí y a 10 probablemente
haya probabilidad que esté enfermo y que
tenga problemas de ansiedad o depresión
que como sabesca es muchísimo más
frecuentes por tanto
esto se puede hacer igual en Europa que
en Latinoamérica probablemente no en
Europa es mucho más fácil porque ya los
horarios son mucho más más cercanos aquí
es mucho más probable y efectivamente Yo
supongo que se irá haciendo poco a poco
paulatinamente en las empresas de
servicios en empresas o empresas
industriales pero donde la productividad
es muy alta y realmente se lo pueden
permitir y sobre todo recordemos las
empresas sobre todo hacen cosas por el
tiempo por digamos por la escasez de
talento esta sería la variable
fundamental pues mire Muchísimas gracias
virginio Gallardo socio consultor de
humanoa y experto en gestión del cambio
y recursos humanos un agradecimiento por
su análisis Muchas gracias a nuestros
televidentes quédense ya volvemos con
más de directo a América
[Música]